DEMOCRATS ON THE RECORD FOR WHAT
SCALISE CALLED OPEN BORDERS.
>> Dan: AS WE GET CLOSER AND
CLOSER TO GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RESOLUTE.
TODAY HE ANNOUNCED BORDER
SECURITY AS A PRINCIPAL WITH
FIGHTING FOR.
SPEAK TO OUR NATION HAS SPENT
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
SACRIFICED THOUSANDS OF BRAVE
YOUNG LIVES DEFENDING THE
BORDERS OF FOREIGN NATIONS.
I AM ASKING CONGRESS TO DEFEND
THE BORDER OF OUR NATION FOR A
TINY FRACTION OF THE COST.
IN LIFE, THERE ARE CERTAIN
PRINCIPLES WORTH FIGHTING FOR.
MORE IMPORTANT THAN POLITICS,
PARTY OR PERSONAL CONVENIENCE.
THE SAFETY AND SECURITY AND
SOVEREIGNTY OF THE UNITED STATES
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE
OF ALL.
WE DON'T STAND STRONG FOR OUR
NATIONAL BORDERS, THEN WE CEASE
TO BE A NATION AND WE WILL NOT
BE FAITHFUL TO OUR LOYAL
CITIZENS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP PLANS TO FUND
THE BORDER WALL.
JOINING US FROM CAPITOL HILL ARE
TWO LAWMAKERS.
JODI HEISE AND FROM VIRGINIA'S
FIFTH DISTRICT, TOM GARRETT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
I KNOW THE HOUSE FREEDOM CAUCUS
IS DOING AN EXCELLENT JOB
FIGHTING FOR PRINCIPLES OUT
THERE AND I ADMIRE YOUR RESOLUTE
STANCE.
BUT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS?
THEY'VE HAD THE MAJORITY FOR A
LONG TIME, FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
WHAT TOOK SO LONG TO GET THIS
DONE?
>> I REALLY DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA
AS TO WHY.
LET'S DEAL WITH THE ISSUE, AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SET US HERE
FOR THIS.
AND FOR WHATEVER REASON IT'S
BEEN STALL AFTER STALL AFTER
STALL.
ONE CR AFTER ANOTHER AFTER
ANOTHER, AND AT THIS POINT,
THERE WAS A LINE DRAWN IN THE
SAND, WE HAD ENOUGH AND WE ARE
NO LONGER TAKING IT.
IT REMINDS ME THAT DOWN IN THE
ALAMO THERE IS A MONUMENT THERE
BUT THE MONUMENT IS NOT THERE
BECAUSE THEY WON THE FIGHT, IT'S
THERE BECAUSE THEY FOUGHT.
IT'S TURNED OUT TO BE AN
ABSOLUTELY SPECTACULAR 24 HOURS
BOTH FOR THE FREEDOM CAUCUS AND
FOR OUR CONFERENCE AS A WHOLE,
FOR THE PRESIDENT AND THE
FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
>> CONGRESSMAN GARRETT, PEOPLE
KNOCKING ON THE DOORS DONATE THE
MONEY DOING ACTUAL WORK THAT ARE
SWEATING OUT THERE IN THE SUMMER
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE IN CONGRESS
AND ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE
ELECTED.
THEY'VE BEEN DISAPPOINTED
BEFORE.
NOW TO THE TAX CUT BILL WAS
EXCELLENT BUT THE OBAMACARE
FAILURE AND OTHER THINGS, THIS
IS A POLITICAL REDLINE AND ONE
OF THOSE MOMENTS WHERE WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO STAND UP FOR
SOMETHING.
ARE YOU GETTING THE SAME THING
FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS?
>> ONE OF THE REASONS YOU ARE
LUCKY YOU DIDN'T WIN WHEN HE RAN
FOR CONGRESS IS IT'S DISGUSTING
TO BE IN A TOWN WHERE PEOPLE
DON'T KEEP PROMISES THAT THEY
DON'T INTEND TO KEEP.
THE COST OF HUMAN LIVES
STRAIGHT-LINE COST OF NOT
PROTECTING OUR BORDER WILL EQUIP
EQUIVALENT TO -- THOUSANDS OF
DEATHS PER YEAR, 4,000 MURDERS
PER YEAR.
IF YOU NOW SAY YOU ARE IN
ILLICIT DRUGS, THIS IS TRULY
ABOUT PROTECTING AMERICA.
IT IS RIDICULOUS AND IT FLIES IN
THE FACE OF A SOVEREIGN NATION
NOT TO DO THIS.
IT'S TRAGIC IT HAD TO BE DONE
THIS WAY.
>> COME I CAN SPEAK ON THE
G.O.P. LOSES AND REPUBLICANS
LOSE WHEN WE DON'T ADVANCE OUR
PRINCIPLES.
BARACK OBAMA DID EVERYTHING TO
DECIMATE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND HELP BARACK OBAMA.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL HAND, CAN
HAPPEN ON THE SENATE SIDE?
ARE THERE ENOUGH AND MODERATE
DEMOCRATS?
>> IT IS REASONABLE AND ITS A
GREAT QUESTION.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN THE SCHUMER
SHUTDOWN A COUPLE WEEKS AGO, BUT
WHO WOULD NOT BE IN FAVOR OF
THAT.
$5,000,000,000.01 YOU COMPARE
THAT TO 1.3 TRILLION THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR ANNUAL BUDGET, WE
ARE TALKING A DAY AND A HALF OF
OUR BUDGET TO BUILD THIS WALL
FOR SECURITY.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS, THE
SENATE DID NOT VOTE ON THIS BILL
THAT THEY SENT US, THEY PASSED
IT BY VOICE VOTE.
THE REALITY IS NOW THAT THEY
WILL EITHER FIND THIS OR THEY
WILL SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
IT'S A TOUGH CHOICE FOR THEM TO
BE IN.
>> THIS $5.7 BILLION IS ACTUALLY
LESS THAN ONE DAY, IT'S ABOUT
HALF A DAY.
AND I'M TIRED OF FIXING THE
BLAME.
WE IN THE HOUSE SHOULD DO OUR